selon mena
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
3 2 1 top je vais vous enseigner des
méthodes simples vous sortir de sera
assisté par noëlle buso non mais il n'a
pas pu faire de constat parce que tu
peux pas faire un constat avec un
chevreuil
en tout cas je suis contente emmené ici
[Musique]
rien alors trop direct sur le pitre au
lieu d'acheter ça tourne
[Musique]
c'était journée était une entière à
servir du pommier on a arrêté
j'ai fait beaucoup de 8 en rayon du
disque est évidemment du tennis aux
[__] ballot celui qui voulez vous je
deviens fou ça y est un appareil un
malentendu salut bon ben c'est pas tout
ça on s'est bien fondu la gueule j'ai
perdu mon micro et je vous emmerde
[Musique]
casque à casque si le casque la plus
belle bits de france et
d'outre-atlantique
mais non bar sur le tube i'm sure la
chatte j'avais pu demander et on sait
que ce projet dans trespass pas mal man
[Musique]
conduite accru mois au pays si je te
réponds pas cdt les vols peut parler
la brouille la merde je te casse les
couilles à mes chemises à des vols c'est
l'homme le plus haï terre du monde dont
le plus gros éternuements le l'homme le
plus haï coeur du monde merci
j'aimerais savoir on a créé ensemble
kadhafi bah ouais j'ai regardé il
connaît mes cannes et à l'huile de les
mapuches et chutes répétées
tu étais pas
pour ces jo [__] à 3-3 rhône croit aux
quelques heures plus tard
[Musique]